buying something that's expensive that's
really beautifully made and hoping over
time is going to appreciate now we
already know the story about the
automotive market
it's been a great place to put money in
the last 20 years it probably will
remain so because
this is an asset class that really tugs
at the emotion of many people
that grew up with a certain car or fell
in love with a brand when they were
young
and wanted to achieve that during their
lifetime and here they are thinking
about buying it later in life
when they can afford it
[Music]
a 427 corvette why not put it beside the
martins makes sense to me
[Music]
i mean a lamborghini why not of course
you need lamborghini the design is just
beautiful it should be in here
in fact if you're going to buy one of
these you might as well just leave it in
your living room
i wouldn't mess around with this why put
it out in the street where somebody
could scratch it
when you walk into walgreens the first
thing you're going to see
is a garage full of cars really high-end
vintage cars
right beside the guitars so there's a
common theme here of investing
buying something that's expensive that's
really beautifully made and hoping over
time it's going to appreciate now we
already know the story about the
automotive market
it's already had an incredible run it's
been a great place to put money in the
last 20 years
it probably will remain so because this
is an asset class that really tugs at
the emotion of many people
that grew up with a certain car or fell
in love with a brand when they were
young
and wanted to achieve that during their
lifetime and here they are thinking
about buying it later in life
when they can afford it that's the whole
premise of this so let's meet the guy
that runs the show here
on cars jonathan come on in here hey
dude good to see you kevin thanks for
having me
you got it you got it now let's just
start you've got so many incredibly
different and diverse
cars i want to hear the investment
premise of each of them let's start with
this what is this
um so this is a 1986 porsche 944 turbo
in 1986 porsche created though came out
with the night it was the first year of
the turbo prior to that they had uh they
updated the car in 85 and a half
um they took what they learned from this
is the first turbo this is the first
turbo in 86 for the 940
it's air cooled or water it is water
cooled so all 911s were
air cooled up until 98 all front engine
cars came out from conception
as water-cooled cars um so these were
these were actually really hot right now
for the past
why why would this be hot well here's
the cool thing because
it's quasi-vintage absolutely yeah it's
modern classic if you will so
what's super cool about these is if
you're not a 911 guy if you're not a
porsche guy but you love cars
you don't have to make any really
sacrifice any big sacrifices the motor's
in the front it's rear-wheel drive the
key is on the right hand side the air
conditioner is really good and the
transmission is really easy to
easy to use there's nothing that's going
to scare you or driving and it's still
eye candy right it's
absolutely eye candy what does this
puppy cost uh today this is 39 000
so for family that's not crazy what did
it cost when it was brand
new uh i'd have to call my dad on that
one he sold him new but these are about
i think they were in the upper 20s lower
30s so
you're about the same range there what
would you expect if you bought this for
appreciation i mean a 40 000
investment is not a lot for a vintage
car so what do you think
in 10 years this is worth so first and
foremost i'd like to say buy what you
like
um but secondly from an investment
standpoint you're probably looking
around
four to five percent a year of what
we're seeing so far in these cars
um better than savings accounts exactly
yeah
so and we've seen them come up
drastically every year and this is
drivable right
absolutely it's daily drivable the air
conditioning is great the power steering
power brakes
power assisted steering excuse me not
power actual power steering this is the
classic
air cooled i'm sure this is it air
cooled until 98. it's got the big whale
finn and then well too
yeah yeah cool all right tell me about
this this is an 89 930 turbo coupe known
as the widowmaker
the widowmaker and they're called the
widowmaker because they left a lot of
people
as widows so in 1975 a lot of guys died
a lot of guys died in them yeah why um
so they're pretty drastic to drive
it's a 3.3 liter naturally aspirated
motor mated to a pretty large turbo
and what's interesting about them is
they don't really spool up till about 3
500 4 000 rpms
and they made these cars from 75 tonight
basically saying it's so powerful guys
can't control it essentially
yeah um and they made these cars from
1975 to 1988 with the four speed and in
89 they had come out
three years prior in 87 with a a and 86
with a with a five speed that they
decided to finally put in this car so
this is a one year only particular car
oh
um it's another widowmaker and it's
black black
exactly so so you you really got to know
what you're getting yourself into when
you buy this
you got to really know how to drive a
stick you got to really know
how to work a clutch because you're
telling me you're spinning out of
control killing yourself at a high speed
that's basically the scary thing about
these cars is not necessarily the
acceleration which but a lot of people
attribute
fear to with a turbo it's actually the
deceleration so the wheels actually
nearly lock up if you lift too
aggressively so you kind of want to ease
off
this will scare the best of the best
there's there's no way your fans or
butts around it
this is a pretty incredible car and it's
it looks the part it looks like you said
what you're familiar with the price of
this this is this particular car is 159
000. now we're talking that's serious
money
159 000. again you think it appreciates
three four percent a year
um from what we've seen there was a bit
of a bubble associated with these
particular cars and they've kind of
settled but now they're naturally
appreciating i would say
anywhere from from three to five
uh is fair but this car because of they
don't make air-cooled
turbos anymore how do i find an engineer
to maintain it if i'm going to drive it
good question and unfortunately
those those guys are kind of dying off
but what's pretty cool about these
they're very easy to learn so if a guy's
eager and wants to learn and he
has a mechanic shopper is a mechanic
they're very easy
are there guys that specialize in cars
like this absolutely and
you know for the foreseeable future
they're not going anywhere 20 30 years
from now it is worth the question
um but yeah there are porsche
specialists can you get parts for these
that's the very cool thing is thankfully
since they have become such great
investments porsche themselves have
actually started to remanufacture
some of their old parts so you can buy a
lot of parts direct
from porsche oh that's that's pretty
smart on their behalf because if i'm an
investor i'm saying i'm putting up 150
000 i want to know the company is
supporting me yeah absolutely and they
have been really well and is this one in
good shape this one's in great shape
fifty four thousand original miles it's
[ __ ]
that's it that's it fifty four thousand
you must've been really scared not to
drive it
and what is the economic model for you
do you take these on consignment if you
really love it
or do you actually invest capital or
both both so it depends on the car
um if the car is a little more quirky
you know not necessarily something that
we can find a direct comp
then we'll consign it if it's something
where it makes total sense the buy is
right
the margin is okay then we'll take the
risk got it
that's right way to do it now this
little puppy is a beautiful beautiful
car
i mean the silhouette of this car tells
you right away what it is
and it's got 427 on it which means it's
got a beast inside
what it does in a black stinger to boot
yeah and that's original that's original
is this original paint
no the car has been fully restored it
took about 15 years a guy took his time
restoring
15 years to restoring this particular
one yeah but yeah the engine's original
original transmission
original um uh 427 390 as you mentioned
these things these these go straight
really well these go straight
very well they turn terribly um you know
this is
this you in a small block you can you
can go around the corner you still have
to start
turn about 20 feet before your your turn
but the the big blocks uh they like
straight lines
and what's the price of this this is 159
000 as well this is serious money i'm
serious which is the better investment
the porsche this well that's an actually
that's actually an easy answer
um what porsche did that chevrolet never
did is they produced at a limited rate
so for chevrolet these were always meant
to be the
secondary car when you walked into a
porsche dealership it wasn't what do you
want if this is what we have
so these necessarily weren't collectible
when they initially came out they were
the weekend sports car
that if the guy liked he bought it so
these have always had a bit of
volatility attached to their value
because there's tons of them out there's
there's a lot more than there are those
however they've they've never really
depreciated
in a drastic manner so i can tell you at
159
you're probably safe it's not going to
appreciate maybe something like that but
it will definitely go up i would
expect about one and a half and there's
comps that show these trade at 115
160 000 yeah that's serious though yeah
so clearly this is iconic because it's
part of you know americana
right yeah in a way that porsche is not
this is all over hollywood it's in
movies from the 50s
yeah very very important in terms of
engineering as well this is a fully
fiberglass car
the corvette is actually one of the
first american cars to ever utilize full
fiberglass for its body
and they did so all the way up until uh
end of end of the late 90s when they
transitioned to full composite
this is also a classic it is it's a 911
it is
i'm going to guess it's air cooled right
this is air cooled so again 911s were
air cooled all the way up until 1998 and
they introduced liquid cooling into the
cars
um this is a 1973 porsche 911s
so this is pretty special and you've
stumbled up apart a pretty rare one
as well what does the s designate from
that year so the s is a little bit more
power you had a 2.4 liter flat six which
this is actually the last year that they
made it
and um you had a couple little niche
options you had a sport a sport front
bumper a lower ride height a different
suspension all the way around
optional sport seats a few other options
that weren't made available how much of
this is original
so this particular car original steel
original motor original transmission
original rear end
but it has gone through a near concourse
level restoration
okay what's the price of this 275 000.
oh oh so we're up now
oh you greedy 275
000 will you let me tell you why yeah
tell me cool all right so this
particular car was owned by a famous
race car driver named diego febless
i used to race with hurley so it's got a
particular prominence to it a little bit
i wouldn't necessarily attribute that to
its whole value
but it definitely helps it's also what's
known as a factory sunroof delete car
um it was pretty popular in the time for
people to option these parts comes off
no it is not it's a sunroof delete
meaning they never came with a sunroof
um it was pretty popular in the time
that people wanted sunroofs it's a it's
extra value because it doesn't have a
value it's called a slick top believe it
or not and if you open that door
on the right hand panel you'll see
excuse me yeah on the right-hand panel
you'll see a
little little knob a switch of sorts
right so that's a power window
very rare for for factory options a
factory power window car and also if you
look under the dash
you'll see some what looks like
makeshift ac vents so it's a factory air
conditioning car
as well as the blue carpets the blue
leatherette and the blue what's called
tartan option code 41 from porsche um
that is exactly how it came from the
factory this is not the original this is
the original it's it
this is how it came from the fact that
i'm kidding this guy not driving
no no this again the car's been been
restored completely but this is
how you would have seen it when
delivered wow yeah
okay so that is serious money how would
that appreciate
i mean come on you'd have to be thinking
about the car being worth like half a
million dollars seven years
and you're not wrong in thinking so so
um we've seen everything pointing that
way
again there have been bubbles associated
with just about everything in this room
but finally we are seeing some natural
appreciation
so i'm going to kill i'm going to tell
you that you know anywhere from 250 to
275 today you'll probably see about
again three to five percent in on this
particular car
per year i think i'd put this in the
living room and never do it you totally
can't i mean this is i mean we have a
car we have a vestment that large
in a car and you can't just go park it
on the street you know what though
though the beauty behind them is
actually driving them yeah they're
incredible to look at because they're
they're this but when you drive them
they shock you goodness
it's crazy this is a 1956 mercedes 190
sl so what's pretty cool about this
particular car um it's actually
dark blue over red so it might not sound
odd but they did not make many dark blue
cars especially with the red interior
and what's what's cool is you know the
50s was the time of
they were just starting to introduce
metallic paints this is not metallic
it's it's a flat dark blue this this car
was really the
unloved stepchild for many many years
and it's recently started to really
appreciate a few years ago at pebble
beach a car a black
black on red car sold for a record
shattering 225 and it kind of set the
market
this particular car is also 225 000. so
it did kind of set the bar and you can
the cool thing is if you're not looking
to buy this concord level of car
you can find them for around 150 to the
to the 175 mark and this is
worth a hundred thousand dollars more
wide
correct i can show there there are a few
things so one
we'll get into the nitty gritty um so
it's a 1.9 liter straight four cylinder
motor
um arguably one of their least powerful
and least desirable motors
why would that be exciting well it's not
actually
um but what is pretty cool about this
particular car and two things to look at
are these carburetors so these are solex
carburetors the least desirable
carburetors of the 50s 60s and 70s
everything's the least desirable yes it
is
until you realize that mostly everybody
took them off and they're
then all of a sudden scarcity they're
one of the hardest things to find
especially with 190s
so when you have them they took them off
because they didn't work took them off
everyone put weber's on and webbers
happened to work and weber was the first
company that then created so
i should be excited to pay an extra
hundred thousand for something that
nobody really wanted whatever came out
correct you should be because the next
guy is too
um so these are worth anywhere from
depending on the condition and the
originality of the carbs anywhere from
20 to 40 000 just for these
these sets right there so that helps you
there and again this car took about
nearly six years to finish its
restoration but what's really nice
i'm not a fan of over restored cars and
if you look at things like here the vin
placard and the spec pack placard
and then move over here and on your side
you'll see it as well there's some
oxidization on the on the metal trim
that all
that's all indicative of original bright
work um it's cool to see that you don't
want to see anything overdone because
realistically they didn't have the
tooling to overdo it
everything was hand done at the time
it's actually got a very beautiful
interior
very simple and stylish exactly yeah it
is and everything down from the white
ebony looking steering wheel and then
cool things
these are your turn signals so when you
want to indicate you simply
flick your thumb and you indicate so as
as beautiful as it was it was functional
and practical another thing about
practicality and i don't know why they i
can tell you why they don't do it today
but
this is your sun visor today we put down
this piece of plastic and it and it
completely blocks our line of sight
this is just simply like a sunglass
smart until you realize the reason they
took it away
is because if you hit your head on it it
wouldn't feel good
i'm sure a few people became widows as a
result they learned the hard way back
over to a 944 actually so the white one
that you that we started with
uh again both 1986's this one has about
half the miles at 32 000 miles
that's slow mileage it is indeed what's
special about this particular you know
certainly when you see mileage like that
it hasn't been turned back how do you
know
well i've been around it long enough to
kind of see what's
right and what's wrong there are some
things that that can be fishy and some
things that stand out and
this one thankfully nothing stood out
nothing jumped at you and said that is
an old scam
it's an old yeah it's a tale as old as
time the second anybody could
you know plug a drill in behind the
gauge cluster they did roll it the
opposite way
yeah no this this one everything points
to you know all signs that are go so
um it's graphite metallic over linen
which at the time was not a fact was not
a uh
on the spec sheet to order it was it was
paint to sample as we call it today it's
great investments because
of their their track record they haven't
they haven't shot up massively
until the past two years uh they were
something that you could pick up
and the price of this is 45 000. it's
not bad no not at all again back to that
it's a little bit more than a camry
yeah this is a widowmaker too this is
yeah so essentially they were called the
widowmaker from 75 all the way up to 89.
um because people just couldn't control
the back
because this is not a four wheel drive
no it's not four wheel drive it's
rear-wheel drive no power or anything
my analog steering same same size engine
in this same size
uh this is a yeah same size motor it's a
3.3 liter um
flat six with a turbo charger and this
particular car is pretty impressive with
only
nine hundred original that can't be real
that is real what was it doing just
sitting in somebody's garage
you know uh yes it's for all intents and
purposes a two owner car
the guy who owned it for the bulk of its
life had it for about 27 years
before passing along to a guy who might
have been looking to invest in a little
bit more and price of this
this is 185 000 okay but that for 12 000
miles on it yeah that's pretty good well
you have two options at that point you
can either look at it as
what it is which is a near new car or
you can look at it as a true investment
and tuck it away
um which again totally up to whoever
buys it but the cool thing is
it's one of those go find another
examples and there are a few in this
room and
what you say is someone comes in there
you don't have too many vintage cars
with 12
000 miles no this this is this is a rare
thing
it's a challenge if you bought with 12
000 miles in it looks i mean is this
restored no this is all original
painting because it looks brand new i
know
yeah it's pretty so really this would be
taking cash
buying it yeah and just assuming four or
five percent a year in perpetuity yeah
about that if not more i mean you can
look at it this way if you went and
bought it new in 1986
and you sat on it all those years
obviously that that margin is going to
be huge
however if you buy it today and you sit
on it for the equal amount of time call
it 35 years
the margin might very well be the same
so you're buying something that
looks as new as it did near in 1986 and
then 35 years from now
you might actually have the same result
yeah it's incredible i mean that's very
unique i've never seen one well i can
shock you a little bit more with what's
behind us all right let's look at that
so this is a 1989 lamborghini countach
25th anniversary edition
they made just under 700 of these cars
for the world they were made from 1988
to 1990
and and it was really the last
lamborghini to be built
uh prior to the chrysler ownership which
happened at the end of 1989 and they
introduced the diablo
in 1990. this particular car 1003
original kilometers 623 miles
how's that possible well so this one
people could look at first of all it's
horrific to drive
um it's not something that's necessarily
comfortable to get in and out of
and it was very easy for someone to say
you know what i'm not going to drive it
i can look at it and i can realize it's
numbered
um you know and all all those signs
point to it appreciate
it it could you could drive it out of
here you can absolutely drive it out of
here it's been serviced its whole life
it's got great records and it runs great
um so what's the price of this 425
000. oh oh so real
i mean okay that really you have to
treat it like a piece of art
yeah you might as well put it in your
living room and just look at it if you
want to do that again
first of all if you're a small enough
guy named john luigi and you're italian
you'll fit in it just fine
um you can't you probably can't no no no
i stalled it about six times coming in
here because right when i was the steer
the clutch release is right where my
hands on the stairwell
that's crazy yeah so that this is truly
it's it's a brand new for all intents
and purposes yeah and you can again
going back to the same way you can treat
the
the 86 turbo you can treat this one of
two ways you could treat it as a new car
choose not
choose to drive it or you can treat it
as the investment
i think it'll be very given that it's so
hard to drive anyways everybody talks
about these cars being like go-karts
they're so hard to drive
yeah uh a ghost car basically lying down
on the road absolutely
yeah and this is if you look here this
is about as
wide as the window opens you're kidding
no that's it
that's it so there's some old photos of
guys pulling up to drive-throughs and
having to open the door
the way you back this car up actually is
you sit on the door sill and you look
out because
this is your line of sight when you look
in the rearview mirror that's it
that's it that's crazy so it's really
not functional
other than just looking at a beautiful
piece of art and that's it you know
and for all intents and purposes all
these cars are art they didn't start off
to be
this then no one intended for someone to
tuck them away for someone to have
anything less than
you know a thousand miles so this is odd
it's odd for the brand to see but it's
super super cool
you're gonna find somebody who's really
into this history yeah
the lineage of this car the story and
the fact that there's basically no miles
on it
yes and no you might find the guy who
had the car on his wall when he was a
kid and he's like oh my god this is it
and this is the closest
news he's gonna drive it yeah he could
drive it that's crazy yeah
i love to hear that they drive them
personally speaking it breaks my heart
i know but i mean it's just you you're
putting up
close to half a million dollars in fact
half a million after tax for sure
and you've got to think about that as an
investment you want that to appreciate
over time absolutely
wow take a loan against it oh just fine
[Laughter]
leverage this is a 1963 chevrolet
corvette split window coupe it's
also a one year only car and it was one
year only not because they meant it to
be but because it was a
design flaw by consumers a design flaw
yes so if you come around the back
what everybody gravitates to if they
know a little bit of anything about
corvettes is this so this is a split
window meaning
two panels of glass and unfortunately
when you're sitting in the driver's seat
and you look in the rear view mirror
it makes the countach look like a big
bay window you can't see anything you
can't see
anything um so they they discontinued it
after almost less than a year
some guy designing it never got in and
looked at the rear view but why would he
look at it i mean he designed it step
back and goes wow and
and it works fantastic but yeah it's
almost like a bugatti boat tail look
uh which is rare for the americans no
it's it's a beautiful kind of look
and price 120 000. yeah so this is a 19
again 63. they made them for one year
only
personally what i love about them from
an artistic standpoint is corvettes are
subtly known for being extremely
symmetrical so
if you look down the car it's almost
literally like it's split identically on
two sides and if you look inside
you'll see the haunches on the dash the
only thing missing from an experienced
standpoint from the passenger seat is a
steering wheel and gauge cluster
right it does look that way it's a
perfect symmetry yeah yeah
so this is a really nice car this is
gorgeous this this this pre i'm a
porsche ferrari nut but
this is my favorite thing in here right
now this is a 1971 mercedes 280 sl
what's called a pagoda which is the name
for the roof um this roof right here
actually comes off it's a removable
hardtop
um can't be it can be removed i'd ask
you to do it with me but it's a bit of a
pain
and then there's an easy you take it off
for the season i assume yeah you do you
take it off
there's a rag top there's yeah there's a
chocolate brown rag top to match the
interior
uh this is the final year for the 280
for the pagodas they made
they started these cars the end of 64.
kind of a creamy uh
it is yeah it's like an off-white
absolutely um more of a cream and
off-white color sure
and uh it was so they made these cars
from about 64 to 1971
this being the final year and some
notable things on this particular car
going to be the fact that it has factory
air conditioning and um
it's a 71. so less than 900 cars
produced for the year which is the
lowest produced of all 280s
throughout its inception so price 95
000.
not bad not bad at all really the market
does differentiate these
incredible deltas massively the the
biggest differentiator on these is going
to be conditioned
unfortunately over the over a course of
its
near 50-year existence there are a lot
of people that didn't buy them for
for investment or collectible you know
so they just drove the crap out they
drove the crap out of them and there are
certain things i'll show you if you want
to
if you're ever looking at a pagoda
there's some certain things to look at
so
on on that fender over there you'll feel
it it's going to be a little tough to
see on this particular model some are
more pronounced than others
but there's something called fender
notches and you should be able to feel a
little bit of a ridge well i do almost
if you closed your eyes right yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
so um basically there was this if you
follow the body line that runs more like
a belt line on the whole outside of the
car
was this really cool subtle touch the
mercedes did to mimic
and they they did it did it on the
inside of the fender well
and it was just it became this thing
called fender notches
and when looking at a pagoda you want to
see if it still retains its fender
notches because
when the car is painted it's very easy
with some sandpaper to
take those off and when they're put back
on they look completely fake
um so so that's the big deal somebody
would even understand not to sand them
down
it's a big deal and there's one other
thing that absolutely helps the value of
the car and i'll give you an idea
if this particular car had all of its
fender notches and what i'm about to
show you in intact
you'd be looking at opposed to 95 000
anywhere from 120 to 150. what is this
thing missing
so i'll not necessarily missing it's
what's kind of faded so
if you run your hands along the inside
of this this fender here you'll you'll
almost feel
these round bumps of sorts yes okay so
those are called spot welds
um they're literally spot welds but
again they've faded from over the years
some some examples you can we can see
the exact tack point
um those alone again with in conjunction
with the notches will attribute to about
20 percent of the car's value if they
were in completely intact
the fact that you and i can feel these
is it absolutely helps yeah it helps so
it's been painted so many times that's
what happened
it's had one repaint um now these will
naturally fade over time obviously
um even if the car hadn't been painted
um but
in metal fins it's you know it's natural
way of life but
uh no the this this carbon painted once
prior and they did a wonderful job
whoever looked after it before the the
engine bay is
absolutely incredible and and rebuilt
really to factory spec
these firewalls have been getting very
difficult to find the only thing that i
would pick apart
would probably be that it's a uh it's
not a mercedes battery
which which you could get yeah you can
absolutely and now again to what i said
about porsche
mercedes is also making their classic
parts available so that that helps the
investor
it helps the collector too so and the
enthusiast so this is a 1962
chevrolet corvette what's called a
transitional year convertible
it's called a transitional year because
corvette introduced a very quirky thing
um and they basically if you look at the
rear end of this car
and i'm sure in the video you'll show it
again but the back end of that stingray
um is near identical so corvette at the
end of at the end of 1961 decided you
know what we're going to tease
our 63 design and we're going to do so
by putting it on the rear end of the end
the last 62 that we built so if you look
at the back and this is why they call it
a transitional year
it has this is the first corvette to
where the spine that you would then see
on the on the on the stingrays
and the back of it is near identical to
the stingrays that you've seen here
so again another one-year-old it's
almost like a front of the car it does
yeah kinda with the two two lights
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's a
little a little confused in that regard
this is very interesting so this
particular car is a 97.3 out of 100
on a scale that was invented by the guys
at ncrs the national corvette
restoration society
so you're perfect it is near perfect
yeah it's a it's a three-time show
what's called top flight show winner um
it's roman red is the name of the color
and it's won again those those awards
three times
and the price 85 000. that's it yeah so
we can go back to what i mentioned about
the volatility that happens with
american cars
they didn't necessarily make these to
pitch to the collector to
for us to have this discussion this is
this is pretty cool that we're chatting
about this car i mean it's still money
but it's
it's still crazy exactly and it's been
this price for a while
uh my client who actually bought this
car six years ago paid 85 000 from the
second owner of the car
who had it for about 33 years did he
drive it yeah he did drive it
um which was nice okay with you know you
advertise 85 000 over probably 10 years
and these engines can be maintained
massively and uh to show you this one
um this is so this is a 327 cubic inch
5.4 liter v8 which you would then see on
on cars like the the c2s that came later
um so this is a optional 340 horse but
if you if you want to nitpick it and go
back to where the
the 97.3 comes out of that's the
original generator from 19
1962. so what you would
want to do is if you drive something
like this is you're going to want to
convert that that's a generator a
generator works differently than an
alternator right
um so however again for our preservation
purposes and to win those awards
if you're going to drive it every day
you'd want to put in a new generator you
put a new alternator
alternating yeah absolutely then you
could put that back if you want yeah you
can you can shelf those parts but you
know
just to see how beautiful this was i
didn't want to take it off and put a new
piece in there yeah but if it becomes an
everyday car someone's going to say i
don't want the risk
of that yeah and you know what there
there are certain things that
i step in and say look if you're worried
about driving every day at some point
they did drive them near every day
so it's all here it's up to us whether
or not we can mentally kind of
wrap our heads around that for for us in
particular as well when you come in if
you don't like it that's okay
someone else will you if if you were the
guy that didn't weren't always the car
guy and had this on your wall
it's fine then buy what you had on your
wall don't buy it because someone else
told you to buy it buy what you like and
let scarcity do its work because it will
if you like that video wait did you see
my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe